it's just a a really really sad  situation for everybody  um and we wanted to we wanted to pay our  respects it I think it has touched  everybody  um and has made everybody really  um come together and and like John  alluded to there we'll try and pay our  respects  um as a football club but this was kind  of on a personal level we wanted to just  show that we were also thinking of  everybody involved and we see a small  gesture for us to come down and pay our  respects but if it was important to do  so sorry holds been my home for the past  five years and yeah we'll run Dubai even  me we heard the news and I'm sure I  thought on my nieces and nephews and the  players thought about their kids and  it was certainly moving for us so